[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the sport of skateboarding made
its olympic debut at the games now
underway
in tokyo and japanese athletes have been
dominant winning 5 out of 12 medals
including three gold and as lucy kraft
reports it's a testament to how the
sport
has overcome being stigmatized in japan
meet shimon iwazawa japan's
skateboarding evangelist
a youtuber with over 200 000 subscribers
he test drives skateparks
demystifies new tricks and most of all
tirelessly preaches the gospel of
skating
the star turns are 180 for shimon a
self-described
misfit who briefly dropped out of school
he found
unlikely salvation on a narrow plank of
wood and the friendship of fellow
outcasts back then skateboarders were
more anti-social people that couldn't
fit
in society like like me like i couldn't
fit in school i really felt like i
didn't have freedom
but skateboarding gave me freedom now 23
skateboarding has taken shimon on skate
aid trips bringing boards to
underprivileged kids in sri lanka
he's got his own clothing line
crowdfunds for skaters trying to go pro
and has just published a memoir
skateboarding gave me a place to be
and a future the urban jungle of
japanese cities packed with rails ledges
and slopes
has proven an irresistible playground
for tourists
nowadays these public streets are a
skating no-go zone
among many japanese skateboarding still
carries the whiff of delinquency
if i'm holding my skateboard and just
walking some people
will tell me like what are you doing
that's for losers
or like you're not supposed to be doing
that and yet
despite a lack of space and sympathy
japanese skaters have
excelled at a sport that levels the
playing field for athletes with small
light physiques and exploits the
country's strength at mastering detailed
maneuvers
thanks in part to skateboarding's
olympic visibility shimon said the sport
is finally
starting to shed its outsider status
japanese society has a lot of rules a
lot of restrictions and people are
really getting tired of this
skateboarding is a sport of freedom
people are just really enjoying the
freedom of it
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo i have to tell you guys i covered
when i
used to be in my only sport world i
covered the x games and skateboarding
and how it was like this
rebellious and a rebel kind of sport and
i love
seeing it now on the olympic stage and
seeing the impact in japan
too as well i was watching some of the
biking the other day the bmx stuff and
it's
incredible the rock climbing i mean the
the the climbing
because i love to climb and i don't get
to do it as much as i i've done it in
the past but it is
you know it's it's gotten to the point
now where we're gonna have so
many sports in the olympics i'm
wondering we're gonna have to expand the
three weeks
something something you've seen it in
ping pong they're like toweling off
because it's such a it's really a
grueling workout yeah i don't play like
that yeah and you're like
10 feet away from the table i love it
that'll be our next thing ping pong
competition